good
draft tips is the one that announced a new
program for parents with children with
special needs that such health to
christian casal is with his brief
information on news now in spanish the
money for this program comes from
the american rescue plan for an
amount of 5 million  of dollars is that
it is currently the first in the country
families can obtain financial aid
for education, transportation,
housing and even the technology required
for their children with
special needs visit our
social networks for more information today they will
vote for you to determine if they transfer to
the 6 a las vegas' alameda county officials will
discuss the development plan
which encompasses some 12 billion
dollars and includes an
entirely new stadium for the team
they will also decide whether to use
tax dollars the team 10
next have been eyeing sites for
a  stadium here in las vegas if
a core agreement is not reached  o
and tonight there will be a
halloween celebration at the rose community center
located on weekdays
and children under 10 years old are
invited to celebrate and of course have a
good time as there will be a variety of games
and activities this event will be from 6 to 8
at night and we will have sunny skies
with winds for today here we
present the forecast for the
next few days now the temperatures will
reach a maximum of 70 degrees
later we will see a rise in
temperatures as we receive the weekend
but the sights will be for  the day of the
witches with the temperatures as you can
see there almost at 78 degrees for that
day I am cristian homemade with his brief
informative news now in Spanish good
day
[Music]